Hey ladies and gentlemen please be
upstanding for the President of Ireland
Michael D Higgins accompanied by
Professor David Madigan
[Applause]
welcome everyone at this wonderful
occasion here in this very special place
we are thrilled to welcome walked around
a heron President Michael D Higgins and
his wife Sabina to Colombia there are
deep and abiding ties between Colombia
and Ireland at the present time there
are 10 Irish born faculty members here
at Columbia including myself countless
faculty with Irish roots and connections
and interests and of course hundreds of
Irish students
scattered across the 18 schools of
Columbia University we recently hosted a
visit by the Provost of Trinity College
Dublin here at Columbia where we
announced a dual degree program with
Trinity College so the students in the
program will spend two years at Trinity
and two years at Columbia and receive
degrees from from both institutions
we've just we've just admitted the
inaugural class into the program and we
received extraordinary applications for
the program and more generally a program
like this is about as close a bond as
two academic institutions can can forge
and we really are joined at the hip this
is a time of great social change in
Ireland's change for the good and at a
time of great optimism we recently had a
visit from tarnish to Simon Cove knee
here on campus we had a packed house
well he discussed the challenges
associated with breakfast and these
challenges are certainly real and very
significant for Ireland and but the
goods is that the country right now
possesses extraordinarily talented and
inspiring leadership both in the tea
shock leav rad car and and in the
amazing michael d as he is fondly known
in ireland the president and i remember
the night that the president present
higgins was elected i was at a concert
downtown where downtown
featuring some irish performers and the
great actor gabriel byrne came on stage
to wild applause and it was rather
partisan group i have to say but just
marveling at the very idea that ireland
had just elected a poet as president
his excellency president Higgins was
born in Limerick in Ireland where my
parents come from he studied at
University College Galway at Indiana
University here in the United States and
at the University of Manchester he also
held academic appointments at University
College Galway and Southern Illinois
University president Higgins has had a
career as a poet broadcaster and has
contributed widely to political and
philosophical journals on numerous
subjects before becoming president he
had a close to 40 year career in the
political arena serving with great
distinction as a senator as a member of
parliament at TD as we call it in in
Ireland as well as two separate tours of
duty as a government minister he was
inaugurated as president of Ireland at
Dublin Castle on the 11th of November
2011 as president and indeed throughout
his career he has been a tireless and
vocal advocate for human rights peace
and justice throughout the world
he has brought great honor and
distinction to the office of president
and I am absolutely thrilled to welcome
to the podium president Michael D
Higgins
[Applause]
may I begin by thanking you professor
Madigan for your kind introduction I am
accompanied here by number of
distinguished Irish people in America
they Irish ambassador to the United
States they are ambassador to the United
Nations the Secretary General of the
Department of Foreign Affairs and Trade
of my own the Secretary General of my
own department and many of those who
work very closely with me it is my
practice to speak not in a token way in
the original language of our people so
forgive me for a moment if I say in that
language how I feel to begin with if
it'll Fiat kin or Hassan VIN shall live
a Christian some they go Hawks Newhall
Scalia Conover saw a man with a Flay
akhirah live his Kamala Shin got a Mila
Mila bricassart on 13 Folger add Irish
of Rome Haman is Ruth mavin Kayla I'm
very pleased as any time as a former
university teacher to be in a university
it encourages me to remember and I think
remembering as an active verb is very
very important
I also very conscious of some of the
distinguished people from Columbia that
I have met in the past I had the
privilege of being a close friend of
Avenue very very well Miguel de Scott
the Brockman former foreign minister of
Nicaragua and president of the General
Assembly of the United Nations who is a
graduate of Columbia University and also
of course the different times I had the
privilege of being and having
conversations with a great and wonderful
Edward Sayid
it's a great honor attend to join you
all here today in this the oldest
university in New York one of the oldest
in this country were known not only for
the contribution of its graduates to the
formation of this state and to the
United States but also to the
development of the car show social and
economic life of other nations I should
say I am aware that I'm addressing you
on the anniversary one of the most
potent expressions of the great upsurge
in student and worker activism that
swept the United States and the world
during 1968 nearly 50 years ago to this
day the students of this university
commenced a strike and a series of
occupations and protest against the
association of this institution of
learning with a weapons research
think-tank and also against racial
discrimination the den Dean Henry
Coleman was as many of you will know
held hostage for a day and later
gracefully wrote letters of
recommendation for his would-be
kidnappers I can assure reassure
Professor Madigan that I will not be
recommending a repeat of the endeavor
today nor would I suggest indeed false
imprisonment as a method of eliciting
resolutions that are needed to resolve
or her genuine concerns are they able to
be dealt with by discourse in an
academic community and I was very
pleased to meet the students who are on
strike who were recognizing the
demanding the right to be recognized I
myself am the founder of the teaching
section of the Workers Union of Ireland
a long time ago and indeed I remember in
ancient times in industrial relations in
Ireland being served with one of those
noses as you could guess at the drop of
a hat from a judge and injunction I
think I would urge the University there
is a right to join a trade you
trade unions are part of the collective
mediation institutions that we need to
be able to bring us into new and complex
times collectively economically socially
and so on and I do hope a vice-president
that you will be able to sit down and
resolve this issue in a way that
respects both their general human and
federal and state rights
[Applause]
a possum I remember when I came to the
United States for the very first time in
1966 and to become a research assistant
and teaching assistant professor John O
Connor at Indiana University in
Bloomington Indiana it was my first
visit to the United States and as a
teaching assistant that particular time
we were in the middle of the Vietnam War
and your draft status was affected wish
if you got less than a C in your graves
which put an immense moral pressure and
myself as the person correcting
professor O'Connor's SS I have to say
that in that time those two is the
period of 1968 I think students and
Parris students in California students
in different parts of the world they did
have different versions of what was
taking place
a former later president of France
justified the breaking up of the
University of Paris on the basis that it
had all to do with sociology and
philosophy and therefore if you broke up
the campus you would in fact actually
created secure France I think you I
remember I was in Manchester in 1968 and
there were differences between different
left-wing tendencies some of the least
helpful would dismiss others by saying
he hasn't even read out so so you know
and I think when I think back in it
wanting more it all had importance
wherever they were and I made many of
them there were people who students who
were acting with a vital purpose and my
wish for Columbia University is for it
never as I said in I've spoken at the
Sorbonne at the London School of
Economics in politics and my wish for
them is that they remain academic
communities committed to Chris critical
scholarship never yielding on the great
resource that a university is
for free taught the right to read the
right to rights the right to be able to
become involved in respectful dialogue
with those of differents and the
students of 1968 full of energy they
were inspired and they wouldn't turn
inspire similar movements of thought and
action in beyond those radical years
from the brave citizens who stood for
greater democracy I remember in Mexico
and against authoritarianism in
Czechoslovakia - in 1969 as well of
course the Northern Ireland civil rights
movement on our own island of Ireland
which was demanding an end to over 40
years of sectarian discrimination I try
to tell you because maybe there are some
many people in this room who are younger
than myself what was it like for those
of us to come to place - her studying
sociology philosophy or political
science we were coming really to be
introduced towards then modernization
Theory there was great founding pillars
of the Princeton studies from Gabriel
Armand and Simon Ferber huntingtin
McClelland and others with their
suggestion that the world was moving in
an inexorable unilineal tradition
direction towards development and we
could come and we would dis be asked
about what were the backward features of
our country that was stopping us being
like this successful industrial country
Orlando Falls border that would describe
it later as learning we were how North
Americans were looking through
ideological glasses at all of our
societies you could in fact where did we
fish if we went backward backward we're
on the continuum where we're on this
evolutionist mythology this suggestion
that it was just simply a matter than
the world would move inexorably on with
them criticized growth and that
institutions would be just liked
institutions that were just now
obviously in a stage of perfection
and to which academic lives could be
devoted with ease from all of that I
think it took most of us more than a
decade to critique modernization theory
and see it for what it was with its
quiet racism its evolutionism the deep
methodological and theoretical flaws
that were in it and I have to say it's
not dead yes I think also as well to all
the acknowledged diversities of the
movements that were taking place in that
time in the 1968 what did they speak
about what was in the literature and
there were constant pamphlets being
produced they were speaking a demand for
economic and social justice a demand for
environmental justice you could have a
debate in California on the difference
between social ecology and Deep Ecology
a demand above all else for peace and
all of the possibilities that peace
brings yet the exuberance then of some
of them in the fullness of time people
looking back on it would choose to say
that this is a kind of exotic character
but one thing I am most in doubt with
even now looking back at it all was the
strength and power of its moral vision
the moral vision of these young people
how privileged it was to be young to
have the opportunity been in a place of
learning to be able to have access to
books to be able to do research and to
be able to look out at the world and
think that it might be different that it
might not be racist that it might not be
unequal that it needn't conform to a
single model and that all the course of
the world was important and that you
could be both a poet and an economist
and an anthropologist and a sociologist
and all of this that was the atmosphere
of the time it was not exotic it was a
Mansur patron and it is what I wish for
the student populations of the world
today
it was a year in which one of the most
important voices for peace
for global solidarity and for a renewed
moral purpose both in the United States
and our planet was silenced by the
bullish of an assassin earlier this
month we marked the 50th year since dr.
Martin Luther King was murdered in
Memphis Tennessee 50 years later we are
invited again to live in the shadow of
war with all its restrictions and all
that supporting structures that absorb
the best of intelligence and science and
technology and which see diplomacy as
something to be discarded and moving too
slow on Tuesday I addressed the General
Assembly of the United Nations as part
of a two-day meeting held on the
challenge of peace building and
sustaining peace the good news is that
in the reports we discussed a very
specific repeated recognition of gender
and a recognition of the importance of
youth to achieve important issues like
sustainability and an adequate response
to climate change and in preparing my
remarks for that meeting I recalled the
declaration of solidarity that dr. King
made 51 years ago at Riverside Church it
isn't it is not five minutes walk from
where we are today but it was there the
dr. King drew together all the strands
of the movement for civil rights and
equality in this country
and he spoke of an enlarged solidarity
with those who suffer injustice in other
places he was of course speaking of the
Vietnam War and how when we think back
in it
how can anyone think that they could
ever have justified the bombing of LA
and Cambodia non participants in a war
and if I may quote dr. King it is at the
outset a very obvious and almost facile
connection between the war in Vietnam
and the struggle I and others have been
waging in America a few years ago there
was a shining moment in that struggle he
seemed as if there was a real promise of
hope for the poor both black and white
the poverty program there were
experiments of hopes and new beginnings
then came the buildup in Vietnam and I
watched this program broken and
eviscerated as if it was some idle
political plaything on a society gone
mad at war and I knew that America would
never invest the necessary funds or
energies in rehabilitation of its poor
so long as adventures like Vietnam
continue to draw men and skills and
money like some demonic destructive
suction Chu so I was increasingly
compared to see the war is an enemy of
the poor and to attack it as such these
powerful words of Martin Luther King we
must recall today in the first decades
of the 21st century we are still
speaking of a society gone mad on war
the rhetoric if you like based on a
politics of fear it completely defeats
discussions of the diplomatic kind that
might respect complexity and which
appeared to be moving too slow and yes
in the universities of the world in the
societies of the world there are
beautiful words an Irish for all of this
our word for creativity's clorium
and for imagination it is solely off and
there are in the dead languages in our
hours as a living one many many times
when people spoke about equivalent about
equivalent words and there always is in
humanism the possibility for creativity
in innovation and it is why Martin
Luther King's rhetoric draws from an
emancipatory tradition a tradition of
Rights was also biblical tradition that
was drawing on the profession can saying
that as long as you breed you must be
able to hope but I think it is something
I think that is very serious 50 years
ago
after Columbia University students
sought to sunder the relationship
between the Academy and the armaments
industry
to many of our finest minds are still
called upon or induced to devote their
skill cultivated over so many years and
our Institutes of higher learning to
discovering new and more effective ways
of killing and sometimes of killing and
wounding and injuring without in wit
impunity a joint report of the World
Bank and the United Nations in advance
of the meeting I attended lot this week
indicated that in 2016 more countries
experienced violent conflict than at any
time in the last 30 years
and yes reported battle related deaths
in 2016 what 10 times higher than the
post Cold War high of 2005 a decade this
has occurred in both lower and
middle-income countries including those
nations considered to have relatively
strong institutions which had long been
considered a prerequisite for economic
expansion and social peace i as an aside
say we cannot continue to neglect the
assumptions of the economic models that
if in fact gave us modernization theory
and however difficult it is we must be
able to have a heterodox approach
towards scholarship which will enable us
to recognize cultural difference the
importance of gender and history - this
sergeant violence that I have referred
to at ten times a tenfold increase
between 2005 and 16 can occur at the
very same time as the
internationalization and liberalisation
of capital and goods market often
referred to as globalization and indeed
debated and discussed in this
institution with distinction I think it
deserves our attention a globalization
of trade it might be and globalization
of awareness for ethical interdependence
it is and was not nor indeed does it aim
to be there were outing moments of
course when people genuinely did believe
that this was so well-meaning liberal
advocates of the universalization of
lazy fair in its day such as John Bryson
Richard Cobden leaders of the antique
corn law League of eighteen forties
britain they foresaw a world of free
trade and free capital markets as one in
which swords would be beaten into
plowshares and spears into pruning hoops
as nations made trade not war they
believed that and I respect that they're
believing in it but the First World War
that collision of empires that consumed
a generation of the young and threatened
the old told us the peace does not rest
upon common markets or upon processes
such as globalization
for did not that war begin during the
previous high point in the
interconnection of capital and goods
markets peace as dr. King may have
reminded us depends upon a recognition
of a fundamental dependence and
solidarity between - between us upon our
capacity for compassion and empathy and
sympathy and upon our shared commitment
to institutions through which we may
discern together the common good and
unite behind collective endeavors in the
universities of Europe today how many
from the philosophy departments are
advising the prime ministers or advising
governments how many in any part of the
world and does this water sister
something interesting it is as if
metrics useful as a source of judgment
have in fact displaced judgment itself
and beliefs on the narrowness of metrics
have in fact displaced philosophy
when we speak of nation states whose
institutions whether to habit
intellectual formation or practice tend
to view the world through the prism of a
narrow realism a real difficulty with
that term anymore which in its
distortion of empirical facts realism
that does not submit itself to empirical
tests negates the very conceptual value
of realism itself as a concept or indeed
a philosophical tool and any attempt to
beyond that vital solid energy of which
I speak is regarded by some as
hopelessly knave a kind of as having a
normative moment a normative emphasis
that is doomed to fail in a global state
fist system we are told founded on the
principles of the Peace of Westphalia
curious regio a you said religion to
accept such a conclusion would cost
between nor the very lesson that such as
dr. King sold to teachers nation-states
are made by their citizens they speak in
the name of their citizens even in
authoritarian societies the capacity
exists through collective action and
through imaginative solidarity's to
redefine what is so often presented
presented as an imprescriptible national
interest it is with sadness and more
than on one occasion that I've reflected
on all that could have been not just
here in the United States but across the
world if robert f kennedy and then very
close to the hearts of the irish people
had not been taken from us in that
summer of 1968 only two months after dr.
King Robert Kennedy was an unusual
pragmatist yet he seized the moment and
the atmosphere of the times with
characteristic courage and idealism
drawing upon the energies
the movement that dr. King had done so
much to craft and to propose a renewal
of the role of the United States in
world affairs in this decade may I
suggest in the decades to come we must
prove ourselves discovered in ourselves
to be capable of demonstrating that same
informing moral vision and that same
spirit of pragmatic idealism that
animation dr. King and Robert Kennedy
and others as we seek to meet the
challenges that they confronted in their
time the requirement for just
sustainable and inclusive development
throughout the global world the
resolution of conflicts through
discourse and display mercy conflicts
both ancient to new the imperative to
confront the great inequalities to
divide our societies the urgent needs to
welcome those fleeing from war
persecution famine and natural disasters
we must do so with all Professor Richard
Falk as recently cause that's suggested
in a tribute to your graduate of the
University Miguel de sport abraca man as
ethical radicalism and I sometimes think
about the impact of the communications
technology then has developed since that
time I came to the United States for us
now we know of every famine we cannot
say we didn't know in Ireland there's a
huge response always in relation in
relation to to famines
but is it not the case also when you see
a deepening inequality in all of the
indicators and we have a massive
explosion of population in some of the
poorest conflict zones of the world and
we have an event such as Davos where a
very small number of people present
themselves as gods come to earth and the
television sets of the world consumes
them
and we do not turn a hair to hear that
less than 500 people control as much
world as the bottom 40% of the
population of our planet are we morally
strong to be in that condition or are we
not closer to what Pope Francis has
called being in a condition of
indifference that is dangerous in this I
think - it's interesting to ask
ourselves how can we recover the sense
of moral urgency as I've said professor
FERC called it ethical radicalism and we
do face new challenges they were in the
1960s in the hubristic atmosphere in the
Faculty of modernization theory and out
in cafe shops we were I think people
were struggling to come to terms with
what what was biodiversity not to speak
of the loss of biodiversity the
implication of the changes to nitrogen
phosphorus and sulfur cycles the
catastrophic effects of climate change
brought about by the accumulation of
greenhouse gases in the Earth's
atmosphere they've arrived on our
doorstep now not to be ignored and these
neglected challenges of den of the bad
mortals in economics and of the broken
connection between ecology economy and
society they are now global in the scope
of their threat and they can only be met
by global institute solutions
coordinated in the only global
institution capable of representing the
majority of the peoples of the planet
the United Nations and who is it was it
not then and is it not now trilling to
read the declaration contained in the
opening lines of the preamble of its
founding charter we the peoples of the
United Nations determined to save
succeeding generations from the scourge
of war and to promote social progress
and better standards of life in larger
freedom in larger freedom net will no
doubt be familiar to an American
audience as it reflects inter alia the
four fundamental freedoms to which
France President Franklin Delano
Roosevelt committed the United States in
his State of the Union address in 1941
he said in the future days which we seek
to make secure we look forward to a
world founded upon four essential human
freedoms the first is freedom of speech
and expression everywhere in the world
the second is freedom of every person to
worship God in His own way wherever in
the world the third is the freedom from
once which translated into world hell
means economic understandings which will
secure to every nation a healthy
peacetime life for its inhabitants
everywhere in the world the fourth is
freedom from fear which translated into
world terms means a worldwide reduction
of armaments to such a point and in such
a thorough fashion that no nation will
be in a position to commit an act of
physical aggression against any neighbor
anywhere in the world and these freedoms
and rights required to be vindicated and
secured not just a civil rights but as
economic and social rights and they were
codified in the proclamation of the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights in
1948 in the drafting of which another
great New Yorker Eleanor Roosevelt
played such an important part in
affirming the dignity and equality of
all men and women on our planet the
declaration stands as vital moral
achievements the United Nations forever
it's imperfections and mistakes and they
are many is the only institutional space
where all the nations irrespective of
site and background in history my just
might aspire to be present and to offer
their views those early days Erskine
Childers the third writing about it
spoke about the atmosphere in the
gallery of the United Nations
and the whispers and the galerias they
discussed the prospects of peace and
freedom from global poverty and our new
world was coming into being and their
leaders were behind the signs announcing
the new countries that had thrown off
the yoke of imperialism and later those
leaders would write in their biographies
of how they wept on their way home when
they realized that the promises made
were not going to be fulfilled
Julius Murray raised a typical example I
realize they weren't serious now there
are of course institutional rigidities
contained within the structure of the
United Nations for example the Security
Council the organ of the United Nations
charged with maintaining international
peace and security is dominated by five
permanent members whose individual
visual powers and may I suggest narrow
and often self-serving interpretation of
what they called our national interests
sometimes for a straight concerted
action yet considering the scale scope
and reach and relative success of the
United Nations peacekeeping operations
and Ireland has been asset for sixty
years at any time a thousand the Irish
men and women keeping peace in different
parts of the world the Security Council
has sometimes been able to be moved in
terms of general interest it is worth
the attendance and even the occasional
success it is the General Assembly in
which at its best the aspirations of the
peoples of the world are most fully
represented it was in that form that the
newly free nations of the call a
colonial world came after a long and
unremitting struggle for independence in
different forms national liberation from
old empires to take their place in the
council's of global affairs and you know
what that particular time Erskine
Childers who worked at the United
Nations spoke about how it was done in
Africa the flag of the old Empire which
was in a football stadium the lights
would go out so that you wouldn't see
the
Imperial flag going down and then the
new flag went up and the BBC would
comment a new country joins the ranks of
free nations free to make its own
mistakes and for that Erskine Childers
was fired from the BBC for checking that
comment in the atmosphere of the Cold
War of course newly free was sometimes
dragged into subsumed into the rivalries
of the two bloc's condemned to be proxy
battlefields upon which the two folds
projected their considerable power and
as I'm speaking in Columbia University
was interesting about scholarship all
the Anthropology could study how
backwards society structured their
disputes and then the anthropologists
were all either came home or worse in
tone and suddenly in the new regime
should you use anthropology for peace no
anthropology for new and different forms
of cultural development to know I think
I so recall those proxy battlefields I
was a member of the Irish parliament as
you have heard during the 1980s
I saw Trudeau I had to draw attention of
the Irish people to the subversion of
the fragile democracies of Central and
South America I was in Salvador in 81
writing about the massacre at Morris Ann
Arbor's observer thirunal to the proceso
and the plebiscito in Chile were
punished it sought to remain in office
for life and I was appalled to when the
Soviet Union deployed its armed forces
to crush the Prague Spring and I think
too often how in fact actually those
destructive state isms of some of those
countries have devalued what were very
genuine and progressive alternative
views of economy and indeed of socials
but let us recall that Vietnam and
Afghanistan both suffer terribly at the
hands of both the United States and
India
Union each one in the one place and the
other in the other seeking to deny the
other have falsely perceived a strategic
advantage the end of the Cold War
brought with it the opportunity of
renewed international cooperation the
atmosphere was heady the possibility of
finally acknowledging unfair trade
odious tests great and poverty
inequality an opportunity of addressing
global environmental degradation and its
deleterious effects on the ecology of
our shared and vulnerable planet with
the peace dividend that would now emerge
today labeling us to devote the
resources and energy that had been
diverted to arms production towards a
shared prosperity should that not be the
mission still of universities and
academies all over the world the
prosecution of a theory of interest by
the most powerful a loss of critical
capacity of analytical level a pressure
for even the Academy itself to belong
within an uncritical new to latarian ism
has made moral reflection within the
Academy seem reduce now to the level of
a toleration exotic indulgence and thus
Pope Francis can speak of across a
culture indifference and it is built on
a an impotence
somehow or another stored sourced
originally invulnerability
that leads to a kind of fatalism that
you can do nothing but let the roof of
your house of the world fall in yet
there have been extraordinary successes
upon which we must pin hope one that we
can build some ones that we can build on
the United Nations Framework Convention
and climate change the Convention on
Biological Diversity and the United
Nations Convention to combat
desertification day standards
expressions of practical realism
practical global solidarity representing
not only the three great achievements of
the real earth summit of 92
but the primary
vehicles through which we will organize
our efforts to confront the environment
threats that face humanity in this
century the Millennium Development Goals
and as everyone at this stage found
words too troublesome that would always
be referred to as the in DG's the
Millennium Development Goals and
marshaling member states the
international financial institutions in
the United Nations and its agencies
behind a common purpose and commonly
agreed set of targets they provided an
example of what could be accomplished
with nation-states and international
institutions were prepared to dedicate
the resources to the vindication of
freedom from want I like to speak about
a civilization of sufficiency but there
were failings in the Millennium
Development Goals the MDGs the goal is
the most ambitious of which was to
eradicate hunger and extreme poverty
we're only binding on the global South
in their formulation of preparation the
voices and assumptions of the global
north carried more weights than the
countries to whom the Gulf goals of line
the collectivity of the ghosts of
modernization Theory were powerful above
all now however in this the 10th year
since the onset I think of the global
financial crisis we should acknowledge
that the international economic policy
framework of the early 2000s reflected a
hubristic faith in the efficacy of
liberalized capital markets and free
financial flows a faith that had
dominated World Bank and the
International Monetary Fund since the
1980s the World Bank in its day would
regard agriculture is not suitable for
investment in Africa then it changed its
mind then it printed in another document
education is the next big thing in
Africa and so on if to his credit the
former chief economist of the World Bank
and one of the most eminent scholars in
this institution Joseph Stiglitz did the
world a signal
service by revealing the economic and
social damage visited upon the global
south by the imposition of a narrow
intellectual framework I questioned the
word intellectual yet the framework is
evidenced in the courses and economics
101 in universities and business schools
across clothes what is taught in
economics 101 not one university in
North America teaching fifteen percent
in the history of economic thought or of
political economy metrics instead of
metrics on its own instead of metrics as
contribution to knowledge it has a
medievalist ring all of this
I think of Galileo this unquestioned
form as a kind of natural law of
economics I am speaking of course of the
theory of government and governance that
we now sometimes allow to speak of as
neoliberalism and as others call it to
the ideology that dare not take clear to
clear its name we know its policy agenda
all too well the removal of all
constraints and roads to use and flow of
capital and world the redistribution of
income upwards through sharp reductions
in the taxation of capital and
introduction of charges for public
services the dismantlement of collective
bargaining and institutions of wage and
price coordination yet all the research
tells us again and from good
universities that unequal societies are
six societies and the societies with
strong equality are healthier societies
yes and it is heartening to see that now
the international financial institutions
once responsible to the United Nations
the World Bank and the International
Monetary Fund are beginning to return to
some elements of the wisdom of their
founding father John Maynard Keynes and
to recognise that the regulation even
controlled by the state of capital
flows and the public interest should not
only be permitted but should at times be
actively encouraged does any serious
economist who has studied the subject
for a week believe that you don't need
the state to give a lead in relation to
responding to climate change are
achieving sustainability and then too
there is a growing and welcomed
literature from such as Professor
Mariana Maas acacho on the
entrepreneurial stage and its role in
sustainable economics around the period
above the hubris that intellectual
framework that made it all possible
was the notion that after the fall of
the Berlin Wall
all activity of the states was bad and
therefore all of activity in the private
sector was good and thus we're left now
with the situation of for what therefore
should to state be there
does everything belong to the market
life itself of course there is the
hilarious not love someone says matters
of love and merit marriage should be
left to the marketplace what once seemed
inevitably and ideologically locked
institutions though they are now
beginning slowly to turn their attention
not only to the DHing undeclared
assumptions of bad and dangerous
economic models poor methodology but
also by welcome at the measurement and
tackling of income inequality between
within and between nations and have
recovered something that's a mixture pop
psychology and economics called
behavioral economics this renewed focus
on water Allah does not forget some of
the most fundamental questions of
political economy are welcome and I hope
it will lead to a recovery of the
critical inquiry that is necessary one
that is open to questioning the old and
stale orthodoxy of what is I see known
as a known more deacon omics which claim
to encompass and explain in its
arrogance the tautology of our social
and physical reality on that point and
to finish this if I mention student
protests in 1968 at the beginning half a
century relation
in Paris and in Cambridge students have
initiated protests but guess for what
they're asking simply to be allowed to
be here economics from different
perspectives
they're holding protests in Paris and
Cambridge on the right to have a broad
curriculum to hear the history of
economic thought and an introduction to
different economic models fifty years
after 1968 I believe that something of
this spirit of a long-delayed humility
which may be breaking out for a time
after the financial crisis pervaded the
global north and it informed the
negotiations of the 2030 agenda for
sustainable development that is our
great success which included the 17
sustainable development goals and the
fact that there were negotiated for all
and applied crucially to all members of
the United States the agreement of the
2030 agenda by under 93 station states
here in New York in September 2015 was a
significant moral milestone a departure
for our planet representing the shared
resolution after all I have been
describing the nations of the world to
attempt again through shared action to
end poverty and hunger combat
inequalities in income and opportunity
in gender to build peaceful just and
inclusive societies reverse
environmental degradation create
conditions for shared prosperity in a
world to achieve the larger freedom the
President Roosevelt spoke of 77 years
ago but to do so you must have the space
and the capacity and the willingness to
test the models by which you do it and
this shared commitment is so different
in character from the imposition of any
neoliberal structural adjustment program
of the past imposed by the international
financial institutions or any of the
dictator of the powerful emerging from
the Security Council or from any single
power
incidentally is President of Ireland I
have again and again acknowledged how
proud I am that Irish and Kenyan
ambassadors worked so hard there were a
point about the person at the General
Assembly to facilitate the negotiations
and I'm proud of Ireland's role and yet
then only three months after that
agreement in New York the conference of
parties to the United Nations Framework
Convention on Climate Change came to a
settlement after all the warnings and
the falls down Dolan's and the
recriminations that finally recognized
the demand of climate justice they
acknowledge what is nothing less than an
imperative for survival of so many of
the peoples of the world in this century
the global target agreed to the Paris
climate conference drafted in a crisis
yes even if the objective of limiting
the global temperature increased to
below two degrees Celsius above
pre-industrial levels is achieved
communities throughout the world will
suffer terrible and unpredictable
consequences I spoke to some of them
last evening are sweet to others this
evening let us recall that the parties
pledged to pursue efforts to limit the
temperature increase to one and a half
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
levels if we listen clearly to the
advice and may I say the warnings of the
overwhelming majority of the scientific
community we must acknowledge that as an
additional half degrees Celsius will
have an enormous impact in terms of the
reduction in crop yields the severity of
heat waves disruptions to the water
cycle in the oceans and a course to the
sea level rise we must also acknowledge
that there is some scientific debate as
to whether we have as a species emitted
so much greenhouse gases that we have
effectively condemned ourselves to a one
and a half degree Celsius warming but
fear of failure should not dissuade us
he must spur us into action and these
two agreements the sustainable
development goals and the Paris climate
record they represent a hard-won global
consensus they are a success for
diplomacy
and the means by which we shall in this
century be judged and measured as to our
successful failure of those tests they
had the possibility of being the twin
pillars on which a more peaceful world
can be built not only by preventing the
kinds of environmental disasters which
are big arsons still continue to be cat
conflict but by offering the possibility
of realizing the global solidarity and
its delivery into policy of which dr.
sping fish King spoke fifty-one years
ago that year 2015 then was a year of
hope a moment of hope one that proved
that despite cynicism the too often Mars
international relations the nations of
the world could discern a global common
good and in doing so rededicate
themselves to the founding principles of
the United Nations and now yet the
shadows gather we've already begun to
see Member States resign from their
commitments whether in the temptation of
those who consider themselves to great
powers to return to safe certainties and
old politics of the Security Council and
to the g8 as vehicles for global
agreements or through a new and quixotic
isolationism which would assure the new
United Nations and turns instead to a
bilateralism informed by some kind of
false nostalgia for the 19th century
rather than the needs of the 21st
century we I think in relation to Island
we have been making some progress
I think globally in 2016 as we thought
of what we had achieved in 2015 there
was one good figure military expenditure
was two point two three percent the
lowest since 2000 far below the Cold War
heights of six percent thus presenting
the possibility that our intellectual
and material resources could be
mobilized for a new agreed purpose not
to fan the fires of war but to cultivate
the possibilities of peace
Theatre of tea Chicana yet some of the
permanent members of the Security
Council and now preparing themselves for
a new arms race and the arms racist
industry is delighted but trust by vast
state contracts as it continues to
export weapons of death and destruction
for us-- not at home but in Syria and
Yemen and the Democratic Republic of the
Congo let me be direct it would be easy
for me to say to merely criticize the
attention of the United States to
withdraw from the Paris Accord and to
2020 the year in which its targets which
include commitments to large sums for
climate adaptation in the most
vulnerable parts of the global south are
activated and yes that is a great
disappointment for the entire global
community that a founding member of the
United Nations one which did more than
perhaps any other to inflect the
organization with the courage drastic
spirit of democracy and daring should
now be turning away there is however and
it is my final point a more insidious
risks to our shared global commitments
whether they were made in Paris or
whether they were made in New York it is
that we and I speak here of the global
north and of my country if we were not
truly authentic in our words now here is
words ring in my head they didn't mean
us and that maybe can be suggested we
did not intend to take the difficult and
necessary sacrifices demanded of us over
the next decades and some feel that we
shall not sanction the substantive
change to the global political economy
required by the promise new global
solidarity in a whole with so many young
it is authenticity that the young and so
many of the old on the streets of the
world find missing from the discourse of
our times and they so easily see behind
the spectacles that are contrived as
substitutes for agreements that are
thrown where words that are thrown out
of context
and out of commitment to get the slot in
the news for example more than any other
place on earth the continent of Africa
which will now be the crucible for the
global challenges I have been describing
it is bearing and will continue to bear
the gracious consequence of climate
change with all the possible
implications for the displacement of
people the degradation of the
environment the eruption of new
conflicts over diminishing natural
resources that that will bring by 2050
the continent of Africa will contain 2.5
billion people of these 1.3 billion will
be young people there is the challenge
should they wait for their sustainable
development until the meetings of
shareholders in the north have been
convinced that investment in Africa is a
good thing or should alternatively they
not have the right for Science and
Technology and all of the inventions
that are needed for appropriate
technology to leap over borders like
culture and music and be available to
enable them to achieve their
sustainability by mid-century Africa
will be the continent of the young over
40% of the young people of this planet
residing there
we must not be trapped into seeing this
as a threat it is in fact an opportunity
and when it is seen as a threat perhaps
by some of our European partners it is
that there still inform perhaps by the
prejudices of a staging but still
present colonial superiority complex
with so much human possibility Africa
has the potential to be the continent of
promise and innovation and opportunity
in our 21st century one that will carry
so many of the hopes and the dreams and
the ambitions of a shared planet a
continent where a new symmetry can be
recovered between economy economics
ecology ethics and solidarity built with
science and technology acknowledging
cultural diversity and it can be
delivered with humane purpose
which we will all benefit these hopes
can only be realized if we stir it true
to the commitments we made to one
another in the Lao those months of 2015
if we ask to be authentic it will
require a convergence of vision between
the institutions of the United Nations
the member states organizations of
regional cooperation and if we are to be
serious about it the Bretton Woods
institutions including the World Trade
Organization authenticity respect for
diversity gender equality these are the
gifts of language our world needs cannot
inevitably I think surely the
achievement of the sustainable
development goals and the Paris climate
Accord should guide any attempt also to
renew the Doha round into which is
taking place in great complexity and may
I suggest the diplomacy they have we
have been speaking about now and are the
United Nations cannot be eyed there
cannot be a different diplomacy for the
Doha round if you were to say that you
are speaking with forked tongues the
diplomacy that carries the moral
conviction of the General Assembly and
the United Nations decisions must be the
one that is at the heart of the
diplomacy of the Doha round I think that
this is of course what happened in
relation to the Millennium Development
Goals
that is why they fell short I think so
we must not either allow our gaze to be
distorted or exhausted in the
considerable quantity of rhetoric being
expended a war a consider to be unfair
or inimical bilateral trade imbalance
imbalances between wealthy nations a
kind of contest of the old ghosts of
mercantilism I think what we need now we
must what everything I have said points
to the necessity for a renewed
international discussion surrounding the
role of powerful economic entities
including transnational corporations
after all we should remember as a
starting point in any reflections that
over 80% of global trade now takes place
in value chains linked to transnational
corporations as the United Nations
conference on Trade and Development is
estimated and this is surely even on its
own limited terms not the bottle of free
trade that Adam Smith had in mind it is
much closer to the model of the economy
proposed by Herbert Simon in which most
of the economic decisions regarding
production distribution exchange take
place within hierarchical theorems
theorems that now claim immunity that
now claim impunity I recall the
president of one saying after a case in
Ecuador where the local people had been
poisoned we will fight this case until
hell freezes over and then we will fight
it on the ice and they will shareholder
applause I think where we are now if we
recommend dear friends two years ago the
General Assembly of the United Nations
adopted resolution 72 62 which
recognized the sustaining peace was both
an endpoint and a process through which
a common vision of a shared society
could be crafted in which all the needs
of the people could be met and when he
assumed office the Secretary General of
the United Nations Antonio Guterres
emphasized the conflict could only be
prevented in his words if we were
addressing a drip by addressing the root
causes through the three pillars of the
United Nations peace and security
sustainable development and human rights
that must be the priority of everything
we do I agree with the secretary-general
and he has outlined an ambitious plan of
action which was Ireland's support and
may I finish by recalling again the
words of dr. King when he said in his
penultimate sermon we are tied together
in the single garment of destiny caught
in an inescapable network of mutuality
that mutuality and that solidarity
demands that member states and the
communities that support them remain
authentic to the commitments that they
made to their peoples and each other
particularly to those two landmark
agreements of 2015 and it demands that
we summon up again the same optimism
that informed the United Nations in its
founding moment and the same vigor
energy devotion and title ISM that
Robert Kennedy brought to his campaign
for peace in this country fifty years
ago above all it demands that same
spirit of hope and righteousness that
animation the students who sought to
change not only a university or a city
or a nation but the world and Mayday
over new generation future generations
succeed and scholarship and practice
where often people such as myself have
failed and may their dust give meaning
and authenticity to life and love itself
and may their world conform to the very
best of their shared ethical moral
expectations in life for all of our
global citizens
milah bleakest Rumaki
[Applause]
thank you very much
doesn't takings for those extraordinary
remarks we have some microphones and
it's open for for questions we have
about ten minutes I look for time and
before I do so say it's appropriate
unaccompanied representing the Irish
government by the Minister for Children
Catherine's upon who has been with me at
all of these meetings there she is
representing the generations that will
win yeah start on this side my name is
Patrick I'm originally from our ma I'm a
student at the School of Journalism and
I thank you for coming here today to
speak to us it's been a great honor and
pleasure and given that you've spoken
without any reserve on our global
economy and what you spoke of as new
liberalism
I wonder what you have to say to a to
Ireland's sorry excuse me
we rid of corporate income tax and how
low it is in comparison to other
European nations thank you yes I think
that the issue of tax is one that is an
unavoidable moral issue and in your
speaking specifically about Ireland's
corporation tax I presume I think the
couple of things about it I think it's
an issue that Ireland will address but
Ireland will address it in the context
of course of other how others are
treating if you have for example the way
the tax actually falls on a company and
on profits and then you have all sorts
of hidden assistances which other
countries have which give you any kind
of a very artificial figure but it is
one of the most important issues III
actually begin however as you can see
move Beaufort serifs being explicitly
about what I call Kirk and globe
corporate and Punic cultures and
punitive the corporations that simply
belong nowhere I remember when I quoted
for example how that the value chain is
constructed now let's look at it like
this you could argue in Ireland and a
voter can ask Scarlett where they stand
in relation to the very question that
you ask me as president although I'm not
involved in politics does the same
accountability apply in the corporation
and the answer it does not equally I
think in relation to the new forms of
international capitalism that we have in
many cases is well well worth looking at
the different formations that are there
in relation to capital that will find
its way into productive activity even
using innovation technology capitalism
that will be in
seek to fall on the world like a type of
acid rain which will result in property
booms and so forth so it needs to be
looked at in in its totality and maybe
you know you're right to ask me about
should because Ireland is important we
are not represented in that much in
relation to companies that we have an
Africa for example but the biggest
scandal in Africa without a doubt is in
relation to the extractive industries
and the industry some of the places
where you have the highest levels of
poverty where it would make a huge
difference
you have elaborate arrangements between
elites that are not representative
international corporations and the abuse
of extraction and are they and
extractive industries that are simply in
their accounts even in their home
countries don't tell the full story but
I'm totally in and myself I believe I
don't think that I would win I don't
know how many people would win elections
now by saying in favour that a decent
Society requires the people pay for the
decent Society and that is the way it
should be I think as well as no doubt
whatever in relation to what is
happening in relation to I it would take
me too long but one of the things that
is very very interesting remember I
mentioned about the abuse of metrics one
of these is in relation to employment
economics where you could say you have
reduced the unemployment rate would you
even choose the unemployment by creating
a precarious so if you have a mass
effect precarious spreading across the
economy your figures can look good
metrics are only useful in relation to
in the context of their uses adjusted
and the explanation as to how they are
going to be influenced judgement made
may transparent decide hi thank you so
much for coming to speak with us today
my name is Hana and I'm a junior
studying neuroscience and you spoke
today a lot about ideals as presented by
Martin Luther King or the Kennedys or
even the United Nations as a whole yeah
and I was wondering you know how do we
incentivize in a growing global society
where as you said many individuals
operate with this condition of
indifference and what I was wondering is
I had
incentivize people to go for these
ideals or incentivize these ideals so
they actually become a reality and not
something that people are constantly
striving towards as it pertains to
things like girls education in Africa or
in Southeast Asia or the water crisis
that we're having and keep town right
now and what role should universities
and students like myself and others in
this room be playing in that process
well I think that M artists in and one
of his books suggests about his defines
equality as be able to be able to
participate in your society without
shame and that's a fundamental but I
think one of the things in really in
relay in relation to where I I don't
look at for example the neoliberal
aberration in relation to economic
theory it's built on a very strong
assumption of individualism and then as
a social scientist and scientist to
myself in many cases there is you have
to do have to be able to discuss in the
academic institutions how consciousness
is created how the self is formed is the
self formed through a set of personal
attributes or through engagement with
the other in what form and so forth and
that's the importance of that I I do
think I'm not just saying it because I
just to be here in Colombia but the
university they were versity having the
capacity to be a community of learning
is terribly important and not only a
community and it's we're not sending
sponges to the universities to absorb
technical techne only the university is
a place of intellectual friendship of
intellectual discovery people arrive at
different of appreciations of complexity
at far different levels bees in any one
of the subjects are what else and that
has to be protected
I think the point of the important point
about it is none of the short coats are
working we know that the shortcuts in
fact are disastrous so it is a time for
reflection and that is why I in Ireland
i iveco I would have loved very much to
see philosophy taught as a sec full
second level subject and Irish certainly
are
second level because the quality of the
discourse and the reflection would
increase so your excellency I really
appreciate your sharing your insights
about recent state of globalization
about the state of the current corporate
community and I do have questions
regarding that area so you mentioned
that of these corporate multinational
corporations that were able to overstep
the boundaries of sustainable
development and basic human rights in
favor of profits and so far as I heard
many of these businesses actives are
bound either by business ethics or just
by plain law to act in the best interest
actually monitor interest of their
shareholders which necessitate them to
take these actions so do you think in
order for us to best realize the growth
of making a better world a peaceful
world a sustainably developing world is
it a better idea is it a good idea to
for us to rethink business ethics to
rethink corporate law and everything
like that or is it more necessary is it
better to return to ultimate trol groom
the last argument of the monarch which
is groans well I think that's a failure
you put it you describe the
contradiction very well and but it is
only an intellectual challenge to be
able to combine if you like more moral
rigor and the distinction between
effectiveness and efficiency as we would
discuss it in philosophy one of the
things that's most interesting and in as
you say is I had I ran an initiative on
ethics and you say what you must answer
to no why are we studying ethics you see
many corporations institutions stage and
non station private have protocols the
protocol is to ensure that you're not
cost okay but it is a very far distance
from in fact actually have an ethical
perspective in relation to corporate
behavior it is one of the hardest areas
by far to make progress it's far easier
in the state institutions then
in the private sector because you have a
separate regime of non-accountable
punishments and rewards which can arise
within the company itself and you're
right to mention hierarchy I think which
is a very very very important as well if
people assume that in order to rise you
have to adopt a certain position that is
the difficult and that is the difficulty
in the end in the end about it all you
know when people speak about it's about
living as a most worker you know when
you do we should all the children of the
world go to all of life asking how have
I made myself useful it would be a
fairly limited perspective and yet that
is the message that is pounded out or oh
all of the time you know and that's why
the same time then you get what Sigmund
Baumann would call people consumed of
their consumption how much can you do
who you want to consume and what do you
want to own and why are people having
massive ecstatic responses because a
billionaire has appeared on television
and who knows might have smiled at them
what's wonderful about her there are
such things as ingenuity I'm not an
anti-corporate at all I think that it is
possible to do all of this but I think
you need to do it from a formation and
the base that is both that is scholarly
rigorous I have my critique for example
of that they nearly David MIDI economics
I was with is is simply the disparity
economics
I wouldn't teach it I think it's just
shabby pool economics and I think the
economics 101 is a very sad place in
many of the universities there are many
of the people you would you if you get
her you could come to an opinion I mean
if I notice that after you people get
the Nobel Prize that are converted to
see in the flaws of economics 101 but
even when they have changed their mind
at the economics they still hold on to
and in fact it fate it's very strange
thank you thank you
hello president iggins and thank you for
coming hi my name is Sam Mayer and I'm
here a junior at GS and I'm an NCO in
the Israeli Air Force I you spoke a lot
about partnership partnership in
diplomacy partnership and peace
partnership and and and many things in
the world in in the world as a
generation that was kind of brought up
to be leaders and we should always try
to be the best and tried to be number
one and hey take ownership of our
destiny how do we become partners what's
the number one tip that you can give a
generation of leaders to enter
partnerships yes well first of all bear
say this I think thank you for your
question I actually think that the
weakest literature in universities right
across the board is much of this
literature on leadership I often look at
you know we management Institute's
different kind they may be into year
2018 the ten essential characteristics
of being a leader
the following year 2019 the ten
essential things to avoid bad leadership
and so far I I find it to be frank frank
with you as someone who studied
sociology and psychology I find that
kind of literature not enormous ly
helpful I think what is very helpful is
broader-based literature on motivation
and your question is an entirely valid
one and in relation to innovation you
say let's take it the other way if you
do the other way you're talking about it
is that there is some kind of infinite
version of the self that can be
expressed in a way that will be negative
feedback that will acknowledge you as a
leader the other way of course is is
that everybody who is comes in doesn't
come in with a blank page you are in
fact carriers of cultural elements
you're carriers of assumptions that are
surrounding one but the real primary
test is how do you deal with
the other the other that is in front of
you to play the leadership of the person
for example about it is here is a
question you won't find in the
leadership manual somebody is begging on
the street should you stop and have a
conversation or should you walk on you
see this is the this is again if I might
say so where universities are incredibly
important and ground must be held in
relation to teaching these subjects and
properly then the whole series of manual
is very interesting I as a as somebody
whose books are in bookshops and that
whom you go in and you see there's one
whole massive section on in fact on how
to be a success and then over at the
other sides another section on how to
heal yourself and it isn't either
neither the one about healing yourself
is about healing the world and the one
over in the other side about success is
not about success for your community or
country of the world
it's about yourself so I think that what
people have to kind of rinse this
extreme individualism out of themselves
and they'll have a wonderful feeling I'm
sounding like a self-help now we put it
but it'll be very good
they could even ever drink after work
[Laughter]
so president Higgins I think would be
happy to answer questions all day but
there's a we various constraints here so
how about we just take one more question
and then we wrap it up do you know what
it is you ask the question for review
and I'll answer them in the one weather
would that do perfect in order to be
Democratic Gophers yeah hello president
Higgins and thank you very much for your
speech and for coming to visit the
University and so my question is about
the the wonderful cultural and literary
production of Ireland and there have
been a lot of great Irish writers and
poets such as Yeats and Shaw and so on
and so forth and as a poet yourself I'm
interested to hear your thoughts and why
that might be and and how also one can
live a creative and vigorous life so
over here thank you very much in very
much enjoying your eloquence and
everything you've been saying um I'm
curious you mentioned the UN and you
mentioned the sustainable development
goals for 2030 I'm interested in what
you think the role of injured indigenous
peoples yes is in that and as well as
the concept of European yeah hello
i my name is Rami I'm a graduate student
in the School of Engineering I'm from
the Middle East and my mother works as a
minister in the cabinet of Egypt and my
question to you concerns religion so on
one hand I believe religion is I mean of
course a good in the world brings good
to people and differences of religion
among people is a virtue and difference
is a virtue on the other hand I believe
that
religion is oftentimes you know it
creates difference in a way that is
unwanted I believe it makes people not
willing not willing to concede to the
differences of other people to make them
here restrain from other people and the
changes of the world and things like
this and and I make a distinction myself
between God and religion yes and it's my
opinion that God is a good and religion
has some trouble when it comes to
integration when it comes to yeah
integrate yes thank you thank you for
coming to speak today our name's Noah my
question is as an engineer I deal a lot
with different kinds of metrics and
that's sort of the basis for a lot of
the work that we do so how do you
balance the need for having a technical
understanding of these metrics and being
able to apply them to do good in the
world while also not abusing them and
having that kind of philosophical
judgment to go along with it
excellent there's some nice simple
questions for you there I just made
about a week that I like but it's good
to out I'll take them I'll take them in
in this order first of all in relation
to taste of culture understanding Irish
culture a crucial part of it is for
example the transition from the Irish
language into the English language it's
long before the famine or in the middle
of the 19th century people in Ireland
bears a heavy migratory country realized
that in order to manage in the country
to which you Democrat you would need
English now you did have the Irish who
came today to America in many cases they
were had to acquire that and so would
been and what is very interesting is the
adopted new language in in alizarin in
the English language radiates and in no
case in you take many others is this
irony went on to excel in this new
language but not very an
in their missive way but rather by a
kinetic way they brought a new form of
the language into existence you have it
in Joyce's version of the novel you have
it in John Millington Synge structured
ready to theater it's very interesting
you to know need looking at the Abbey
I'm told in the United States says this
is Direction theater is gone unit and
it's quite global as well and we're
really pleased about that
but what is very very important I think
about it is the music in turn then the
music survived for the Irish language
didn't to some extent the Irish language
is still a living language now but the
music travelled across the Atlantic and
went to the Appalachians it has engaged
jazz elements it engaged with other
elements so did dance
so it has engaged the Irish culture has
a very strong migratory core as its
center in every single form of the of
the Arts form and you will find a whole
stone relation to the song tradition the
notion of exile and leaving and and and
that is there but it's something that we
welcome both what is very very
interesting to is when you kind
of get technical language and we will
say we must encourage people to innovate
and so forth creativity is there in its
broadest sense and the advantage of
artists and others is that they are able
to imagine what doesn't in fact actually
is in front of you and so forth and
that's powerful people affair to do that
in conditions of provision in conditions
of wealth I think in relation to the
indigenous question I think it's very
very important I visit I was visited but
you know if Steve is that I made to Peru
by some indigenous people from Putumayo
but it is one of the things that is the
great losses I could give you an example
a practical one which is in relation to
let us say our culture that elsewhere
this week is in relation to Somalia I
was in Somalia during the Somali and a
famine and
mr. Sun noon from North Africa was the
United Nations representative about to
lose his job because the bigger powers
were getting impatient
the only way to solve the flow of young
people into the to warlords in Mogadishu
was the to use the elders and the clan
system but the clan system is a system
of mediation of justice and generosity
no more than than the indigenous systems
of how do you behave with generosity if
your case has been vindicated which
success in the African system we've paid
a terrible price for neglecting the
setting of death when we seek to bring
resolutions and mediations intercultural
settings and awareness of what would
have been traditional said dealings with
things would have been a great advantage
and has often been ignored I think in
relation to there is a stirring of the
movements in relation to the South
America and particularly the present
times in relation to indigenous rights
they're the most neglected rights and I
spoke about it and when I visited
Australia I I found the question about
religion and and a very very interesting
I'd only say this which is interesting
you're quite right it is where in fact
belief systems are most of the main
religions I think those who are when
you're approaching it as a scholar is
that you'll continually invited and
reminded that you're to stay studying so
therefore it is never I spoke to someone
ll this week about it it's not a case of
trading certainties it is when things
gets reduced not just to a certainty but
into an instrument of division and an
instrument exclusion that it gets
dangerous in relation to add a former
president of the of the the Richard Falk
essay that I quoted which was a tribute
to Miguel just gota Brockman for mr.
Nicaraguan for president of the General
Assembly the a say that Richard Falk but
rightly gave to it was spirituality and
its contribution to diplomatic
creativity something like that so the
notion of for example if where it gets
really bad I think is there's the Asian
century in the European tradition what
we will call the European enlightenment
it begins where as the displacement of
superstition and then it becomes a
service a servicing tool of colonization
Imperial in the second half of the
Enlightenment and then you have
significant scholars like either holders
who are in fact actually Phyllis
philosophers arguing enlightenment
philosophers arguing against
colonization so the retention of the
concept of mystery and of mashes being
unfinished and being open is what i
think it just go to a call horizon
effect and i think that's the
distinction between the different
political systems in relation to the
question about the Frankfurt School and
TechNet and the one that my remarks
about metrics it's it's very interesting
many of the metrics first of all I think
it's important it to to to respect the
mathematics that's below the measure and
also I think what I'm saying is metrics
can be very good as summary particularly
as forms of communication to people but
here is where a query can get go wrong
is if you have it it's rather like the
business schools again if it becomes
organizational theory if you not in fact
making it clear how the measurement is
fishing your approach to knowledge and
understanding you end up in fact with a
whole series of little dots that have
been joined together but in fact missing
the big picture and other one of it is
interesting in the history of management
theory in relation to that is that you
know when you had before just after Ford
is Amanda all of the rest of it the idea
was is that all intelligence is actually
withdrawn from the productive space and
now exists in the boardroom
and then within the boardroom as well
you would get associate directors and
you'd get executive directors and
therefore what you are really saying is
is they're all intuitive wisdom and
knowledge exists in this narrow space
but how then are the people who are
working on the floor to function and the
suggestion would be well they don't need
to know what it is that they're
producing or doing and that is one of
the huge big shifts in relation to
organization theory where it now is and
where it is going is that we are going
to have to redefine all of that I'm I'm
I have to I'm writing a paper on the
future of work for the ILO from Geneva
in May or something like that I have to
do but it's it's a really it's a
baffling one but the most important one
it arises in markussi as well in
relation to that particular period when
when he's working as an assistant and
and he's dealing with this issue III
guess in my final point which is an
interesting one it is in relation even
in relation to the distinction between
the contribution after of the Frankfurt
School in relation to neo-marxist theory
that it wasn't only about expropriation
and exploitation at the point of
production then it was about domination
and from once you hand introduced
domination you were able then to deal
with relationship between men and women
and you could deal with with the gender
issues but also there was the other
issue which is very very interesting in
relation to sexuality itself and that is
about the relationship between two
people as two full persons and the
gradual breaking down of for example two
full relationships to sexual
relationships and then the location of
sexuality in different parts of the body
and this in turn which he was very well
aware of it at the Frankfurt School was
how all this had been changed by the
factory system so therefore you would in
fact actually therefore even in our
contemporary world have suggestions that
there's relationships that are full and
satisfying have in fact to be in certain
spaces of recreation that are defined by
Dom
cultures open to advertising and one
becomes a slave to the technical rather
than a liberation in relation to
sensuality per man good luck thank you
everyone and thank you for joining us
this afternoon and thank you the
president mrs. Reagan thank you very
much ladies and gentlemen please remain
in your seats as we escort president
Higgins and delegation out of the
rotunda